Mujtaba: Today, we're going
to learn about Ohm's Law.
Mujtaba: I'm curious how
many of you have heard of
or know about Ohm's Law?
Student: I know.
Student: I do.
Student: I've yeah, yeah.
I've heard about it.
Yeah.
Mujtaba: So the simplest way it
is represented is V equals IR.
That is, the voltage drop,
or the potential drop
across a resistor
in this case is
just the current that
passes through the resistor
times its current.
So if we were to draw a resistor
right here with a value R,
and this is the current,
then the voltage drop
across this resistor, this V
is equal to the current times
that resistor value that the
resistor has so the resistance
value of the resistor
and the current path
that passes through it.
Current is the flow of electrons
and V is the potential.
So think of it as a
force essentially,
that allows or enables
these electrons
to move from an area
of higher potential
to low lower potential.
So if you guys have drunk
boba bubble tea before,
what happens is in
the cup, you guys
have these bubbles
at the bottom.
And when you try to at
the end, once you're
done with your
drink, you're trying
to suck these bubbles up.
The when you're trying
to suck these bubbles out
of this straw, the pressure
that you're putting on to it
is essentially analogous
to this voltage
and the flow of these
bubbles in this straw
is essentially like the
current and the resistance
is essentially the friction of
these bubbles with this straw.
And that is the
pressure you will
need to overcome the
flow of these bubbles
in this straw against this
friction to to get it.
This is essentially
analogous to that.
So what we're doing
is essentially this.
Oh, sorry about that.
This concept is
pretty much described
in almost every high school
and high school physics
and early college physics.
But a lot of people have a hard
time using this in real life.
So one of the ways we can use it
is if we have a simple circuit.
Mujtaba: So if we
have a simple circuit,
and we have an LED here.
Mujtaba: So
essentially, these are
little light
bulb-looking things that
emit light when you drive a
current through them so they
light up.
So in a circuit like
this, what happens
is we have a potential drop
or voltage source right here.
Let's say it is two volts.
And there's a
resistor right here.
And we need a current
to flow through this LED
to light it up.
So right here I have
a red LED that I'll
show you guys in a minute.
But red LEDs have a current
rating of 20 milliamps.
And in order to make a
circuit where we can light up
this red LED, we
need to know what
should be this resistor value
for the current in the circuit
to be exactly this current
that this LED needs to turn on.
Mujtaba: Okay, so we will
be finding this resistor
value to do this, and this
is a real-life application.
For example, if you want
to turn on this LED,
so we will need to use Ohm's Law
right here--V equals IR to do
this.
And we know the voltage--two
volts--and we know the current
that is 20 milliamps.
Mujtaba: So if the current
is 20 milliamps what
would the resistor value be?
Student: 100.
Mujtaba: Exactly.
So, now we will use
this in a circuit
and see if our LED turns on.
So I'll share my camera with
you guys and see if this works.
Mujtaba: Can you
guys see me now?
Students: Yes.
Uh huh.
Mujtaba: So now.
Okay, so now what we
have is the circuit.
Mujtaba: Can you guys
see this circuit?
Students: Yeah.
Mmm hmm.
Mujtaba: We will be not
worrying about this part
of the circuit for now.
So the only thing we worry--we
worry about is so there is
a two volts input right here
in this port and we found that
a resistor value of 100
ohms will do the job,
so this is 100 ohms resistor and
we will plug this in from a two
volt source in this breadboard,
so this is a breadboard.
If you guys have dealt with
prototyping electronics
you might have used this.
It's just a bunch of holes that
are connected to each other.
So all these five holes in a
row are connected to each other
and the columns
are not connected
so you can use them to
essentially make your circuit.
So we will be connecting
that there and we will
be using a red LED.
This is an LED, and
this one is a red one.
And LEDs have two
legs, essentially.
The longer one is
the positive one
because they're directional.
And if you connect
them the opposite way
they don't turn on.
So the longer leg
will go to positive
which is connected to
the resistor essentially,
and then the negative
one will go to ground.
So we will connect
this right here.
Mujtaba: And we will
connect the other leg to
Student: I can't see it.
Mujtaba: Oh sorry.
Yeah.
So we will connect the other
leg to ground over here.
Mujtaba: So yeah, so
ground right here.
So in this breadboard, I've
set up this rail at the bottom.
So this negative the blue rail
is ground and the positive rail
is the positive volts that
I'll connect the battery to.
And I have a voltage
divider set up right here
that I'll explain in a minute.
But this essentially takes
my battery which is nine
volts--this is a nine volt
battery and divides this
into essentially the required
voltage that I need and that is
two volts right here that
will go into the resistor.
So we will connect this battery
now and see if it works.
Mujtaba: Can you guys see?
Mujtaba: There we go.
So we will have a closer.
I will connect the battery...
Mujtaba: battery pin
Mujtaba: Do you see that?.
Student: Yes.
Mujtaba: The red LED turns on.
So this is a real-life
application of this.
Mujtaba: So, of Ohm's Law.
You can use it to turn on LEDs.
You can use it for your personal
projects or anything like that.
You can buy LEDs,
they're very cheap
and you can set up the
circuitry on your own
and make an LED turn on and
do a lot of other cool things
with it.
Mujtaba: Now, LEDs
have--any questions so far?
Student: No.
Mujtaba: Okay, so now LEDs
have different current ratings.
Essentially, if you're
turning on a red one,
you need a different
current to go through it.
And if you're turning
on a blue one,
you would need a different
current to go through it.
Mujtaba: So a blue one, so
this one needs 20 milliamps
to go through it to turn on.
A blue one will
need 30 milliamps
to go through it to turn on.
Do you guys think if I switch
this red LED with a blue one,
will it turn on right now?
Student: Probably not.
Mujtaba: Exactly.
It will not turn on
because because we set up
this circuit for a 20
milliamp current, which
is lower than the
30 milliamp current
and that's why the blue
one will not turn on.
We can test this and
here I have a blue LED.
And we can--
Mujtaba: we can plug
in the blue LED.
Mujtaba: Okay, now I
can plug in the battery
and see if it works.
Mujtaba: Oh, battery
is connected,
but the blue LED does not
turn on, or it's very dim.
No, I don't think
it's on at all.
So, in order to do this--to make
the blue LED turn on--what do
you guys think the
resistor value should be?
We know the voltage
is two volts.
We know the current
to be 30 milliamps.
What should the
resistor value be?
Student: Lower than
this one by two thirds.
Mujtaba: Exactly.
Something like 67 ohms.
Mujtaba: So, if
you plug in that,
we can turn on the blue LED.
Mujtaba: So now I will
go on to the concept
of the voltage divider
which essentially
is the reason we can take
the nine volt battery
and connect it to it without
burning anything down.
And that is essentially when
resistors are in series,
that is they're
connected to each other
and they divide the voltage
that goes through them.
Think of it as having two
bubbles in your straw.
When you're trying to
pull out the bubbles
at the bottom of
your boba drink,
if you have two
bubbles in the straw,
you need to suck on it a
little harder or essentially
the pressure drop
across the pipe
needs to be higher for both
of those bubbles to come up.
And that is essentially
what happens here.
So two resistors in series,
divide the voltage across them
depending on the
resistor value they have.
Mujtaba: So without
going to my screen,
I can just use paper here.
Mujtaba: So that is
Mujtaba: Can you guys see this?
Students: Yes.
Mujtaba: Okay.
So if we have one resistor
in series with other resistor
and if they're--so, the sum of
them the voltage drop across
one of them, so say there is a
voltage drop across the whole
thing, this goes the
opposite direction, okay.
So the voltage drop across
one of them--this is R1,
this is R2--will be the resistor
value of one over the sum
of both of them times
the voltage okay?
Mujtaba: So, essentially the
voltage drop across one of them
will be the
resistance of that one
over the sum of both of them
times the total voltage.
Mujtaba: So, that
is essentially what
we are using here to do this.
So in order to get
two volts out of this,
what do you guys think the
ratio of these resistors
is supposed to be?
Essentially, this one resistor
over the sum of resistances
times nine should give us two.
And that way we can
find two divided by nine
should be the ratio
of these resistors.
And that is essentially
the resistor value that I
picked--it's random.
So you can pick many different
combinations that gives you
that ratio, which is
I think 0.2--0.22.
So to get that I chose 1.6
kiloohms resistor and a 5.6
kiloohm resistor.
And as you guys can do the
math, 1.6 over the sum of both,
which is seven
point two will be...
it's a little odd ratio
but it will be 0.22.
So that times nine gives us
the two volts that we need.
And that is essentially what
I'm doing in this circuit right
here.
Mujtaba: In here.
Mujtaba: So you guys can see
the two yellow resistors.
Those two yellow resistors,
one of them is 1.6.
The one that is
horizontal is 1.6.
And the other one is 5.6.
And 1.6 over the
sum of both of them
gives us the ratio
and that connected
to the battery which is the
blue and red rail at the bottom.
Mujtaba: Right here.
Mujtaba: This rail is nine volts
and that divides it and make
to two volts.
And that's how we find the two
volt from nine volt battery.
Mujtaba: Okay.
Any questions
Student: Hmm I have a question.
Mujtaba: Yeah.
Student: Like when
we connect something.
So, in in the
voltage divider, we
can add something that has
like finite resistance.
So, we change effective
resistance of one
of the resistors
in voltage divider.
How like how can how do we
need to pick resistances
of voltage divider by the
resistance to make this more--
Mujtaba: Which affects lower?
So you are you talking about
the two volts that at the end
we are getting you want
to make that lower?
Student: No.
I mean like there are two
volts in the voltage voltage
divider if you don't
connect anything to it,
but if you connect something
the effective resistance
of something we
connect and resist.
And there's a
resistance too, which
we connect with the scheme
in parallel, changes.
And we want to have two
volts, exactly two volts.
Mujtaba: That is,
that is correct.
That is correct.
If you connect it in series, it
changes the effective voltage
drop or the effective
resistance and therefore
the effective voltage
drop across one resistor.
But, so the way it is
connected to this circuit,
and this diagram or in
any other situation when
you're connecting
something, you're
usually connected in parallel.
So in parallel, the
voltage drop stays the same
across both of those
parallel things.
Ideally, that would be the ideal
scenario, but in real life,
there is a slight drop across
the parallel setup because
of the losses in the circuitry
and all the other things,
but in in theory, when you
connect things in parallel,
the voltage drop across both
of them will stay the same.
And that's why the LED circuit
is connected in parallel
to the 1.6 volts or
1.6 kiloohm resistor
and therefore the voltage
drop across that resistor
stays two volts only.
Student: What would happen if
too much current run through,
yeah, LED.
Mujtaba: So the
LED is essentially
a piece of material that has
electrons at certain transition
states.
So the way it emits emit
light or emits light
is essentially activation
of those electrons.
And that's how it
emits light and it
requires certain energy level to
cause the activation to happen.
If there's too much energy, and
most of the commercial ones,
they just break.
So the LED just breaks and
if you put too much current
through it, it just breaks
and they will not work again,
which essentially means that
the material whatever they're
using in there just melts
down or the energy for it
is too much.
And some of the other cases,
if you put too much current
through a thin wire,
especially when it's it
doesn't have a heatsink
in any other way.
It will just melt down.
So in short answer
LED just breaks
and you will not be
able to use it again.
Mujtaba: Yeah.
I hope that was clear.
You can use it in
your own projects.
One of the projects I
actually made was a clock.
I made a clock for my room.
I don't have it here
right now but it
was a clock that was controlled
by by an Arduino which
is just a microprocessor.
And each of the twelve numbers
on the clock were LEDs.
And it would turn on
depending on the hour
and the minute of
the day it was so you
can use a simple calculations
like this like ohms law
and practice to
find the resistor
values for the
different LEDs that you
will be using in that case,
the clock for example.